Let's work on forming the /aʊ/ sound.
The tip of your tongue is relaxed and touching behind the lower front teeth.
Your tongue moves from front low /a/ to back high /ʊ/ in a very big movement.
/aʊ/, /aʊ/, /aʊ/, /aʊ/, /aʊ/.
Your jaw will move a lot too.
The lips move from relaxed with the first vowel /a/, to rounded with the second vowel /ʊ/.
/aʊ/, /aʊ/, /aʊ/.
Here's the /aʊ/ sound in the beginning of some words.
Owl, Ouch, Outside.
And here it is in the middle.
Sound, Mouse, Shout.
Here it is at the end of some words.
How, Now, Cow.
Listen to these pairs of words to hear the contrasting sounds.
Out, Ought.
Bound, Band.
Now, Know.
Here are some sentences that use the /aʊ/ sound.
The mouse came out just now.
I heard a sound like a shout from outside.
/aʊ/, /aʊ/, /aʊ/.